this is Resident Evil 4.
today is one of the most if not the most
acclaimed Resident Evil games at the
time it received a 96 out of 100 average
rating according to Metacritic and its
remake received a 10 out of 10 from
Gamespot here's what our reviewer Kurt
had to say about it I can't stop playing
it and most importantly Resident Evil 4
saved the entire Resident Evil franchise
and this is how
[Music]
was a fantastic game by 2005 and after
12 games the formula was starting to
grow stale
and it was things like well this opening
a door Q door opening loading screen and
look even Luigi's Mansion was copying it
by this point
yoo-hoo the thing is ever since Resident
Evil 1 released in 1996 and defined
survival horror as a genre horror game
is inspired by it began to rapidly
emerge with most of them proudly wearing
their Resident Evil 1 inspiration 1998's
Parasite Eve Resident Evil meets Final
Fantasy 1999 Silent Hill Resident Evil
means psychological horror 2002's
Eternal Darkness Resident Evil meets
lovecraftian horror 2001's Fatal Frame
Resident Evil meets a camera 1999's Dino
Crisis Resident Evil meets Dinosaurs
the first Resident Evil set the stage
for the genre but a sequel took the
series to staggering Heights of critical
and Commercial Acclaim Resident Evil 2
sold a whopping at nearly 5 million
copies on the PlayStation 1 alone to put
that in late 1998 context for you Gran
Turismo was the highest selling game on
the PlayStation 1 with 10 million copies
sold so re2 was one of the standout
successes of the original PlayStation's
entire lineup
but like a freshly bitten zombie victim
the survival horror genre eventually
started to fall apart in many ways and
there was a decline in both interest and
ideas newer games like Fatal Frame while
getting a niche audience were failing to
succeed in a major way meanwhile
established franchises like Silent Hill
were faltering and even the mighty
Resident Evil was on its way down after
creating a genre the Resident Evil
franchise meanderth through emerging
Trends and Capcom threw out more than a
couple Hail Mary attempts at Reinventing
it with various offshoot games and the
main number of games were starting to
feel a little repetitive
but fortunately Shinji mikami the
original creator of Resident Evil and
many on his team at Capcom were
themselves sick of making the same thing
over and over again and felt it was time
for a massive change I'm talking
completely stripping down the
fundamental mechanics that may Resident
Evil well Resident Evil and making
Resident Evil still Resident Evil but
not Resident Evil
hold on I just confused myself
one of the things that made Resident
Evil was its static camera every scene
had a slightly different camera angle
and it allowed the developers to play
with framing to enhance the atmosphere
of the game for example they would make
the camera crooked to induce a feeling
of something being off or put it in a
specific location to block you from
seeing enemies around the corner in
other words it helped add to the tension
of the game on top of that because the
camera was static it meant they could
use pre-rendered backgrounds and walls
making the game look far more realistic
than it otherwise would have on the
limited PlayStation 1 Hardware this was
also the case in the GameCube remake
which seriously still looks good today
ari1 made the GameCube hit the gym and
finally stopped skipping leg day
but the idea with Resident Evil 4 was to
change things up and Shinji mikami would
be inspired by a game that was in a
series that was ironically enough
inspired by Resident Evil
onimusha 3 demon Siege ninja Resident
Evil Oni Musha 3 is a third person
action game and notably the Viewpoint in
the game is the standard third person
action perspective at the time from far
away in the distance so you can see
everything going on but why why is it so
far away what the hell the game would be
so much better if the camera is placed
closer to the character or maybe even
like right behind the characters
slightly over the back of the shoulder
so you feel like you're right into
action the game could have been so much
more or so Shinji Megami felt while he
was playing the game you see he wasn't
actually inspired by what the game was
so much so as he was inspired by what he
wanted the game to be so in his new
Resident Evil game mikami placed the
camera right behind leonen over his
shoulder and believe it or not this had
never been done before anywhere at least
not nearly as effective as this before
Resident Evil 4 the game that action
games were at the time heavily inspired
by was Max Payne a a game that had his
camera set higher and further back from
the character some of the most popular
and successful games like Ninja Gaiden
had a similar camera because the
developers wanted you to be able to see
what was happening so when Resident Evil
4 did this with its camera it was truly
a revolutionary this single camera
placement change completely changed the
course of gaming Forever Without re4 You
don't get dead space okay that one was
kind of obvious slow-hanging fruit let
me try again without re4 you don't get
Gears of War a game that Creator Cliffy
B admitted was directly inspired by
Resident Evil 4 and paved the way for an
entire generation of over-the-shoulder
action shooter games it was basically
Resident Evil 4 with a cover system
without re4 you don't get games like
Mass Effect or Batman Arkham Asylum or
their subsequent fantastic sequels at
least in the way we know them today the
ripple effect of this camera system went
beyond Resident Evil and impacted the
entire games industry of course this new
camera system them was combined with
[Music]
a brand new aim mechanic remember this
is classic Resident Evil aiming you can
point the gun straight up at the ceiling
or down at the ground even though you're
in one of the most prestigious and elite
special forces units called Stars this
is how you aim I'm just saying that
apparently you didn't need target
practice to join Stars okay Dave now aim
for the head no the head try again Dave
the head head
damn it Dave
that's the most beautiful aim I've ever
seen while from a practical standpoint
the characters had terrible aim from a
survival horror standpoint it made the
game more scary take it away Susie what
makes the shooting really effective in
Resident Evil one is it's one automated
or if you're playing the original
original release of re1 uh manual aim
which is extremely hard to do from a
fixed camera perspective but yes also
that fixed camera perspectives not being
able to see what you're shooting at most
of the time and it just it makes for a
really enjoyable horror game so that's
the goal I think they nailed it so for
Resident Evil 4 Shinji makami did the
unthinkable he made it so you had full
control over your aim wow wow wow wow
wow wow you're so dominant this madman
was taking the fundamentals of what made
Resident Evil scary and systematically
stripping them away spooky cinematic
static camera angles nope we have a new
camera system out with it difficulty
aiming in an extremely limited ammo nope
Leon can now fully aim from his behind
the shoulder camera and make every
bullet hit the mark it was a giant risk
and amazingly it paid off because while
the tension couldn't be created by
hidden zombies who were just out of
sight from the camera or you know aiming
at the ceiling when you want to shoot a
zombie's head instead re4 could use all
sorts of new tricks to scare you as a
player and add a different kind of
tension mostly thanks to
Imagine This if you will you're playing
Resident Evil 1 you walk into a Village
area with 15 different camera angles
terrible aim and you get ambushed and
sworn by like 30 plus zombies all at
once you are dead it's over there's no
way you'd survive this but in Resident
Evil 4 as you have more control you
could do this suddenly Resident Evil 4
was able to add in what's now in my
opinion one of the most iconic moments
in all of gaming a moment where at the
opening of the game just as you think
you're starting to get the hang of the
new controls and mechanics of re4 it
ambushes you with a zombie apocalypse
and if you weren't sweating profusely
and screaming like a maniac when a dude
with a mother [__] chainsaw suddenly
appears and rips your head off Well you
aren't a human because that's the human
response to this re4 like really relies
on positioning and awareness of your
surroundings because while you do have a
lot more uh control and capability in
that game you're still operating on tank
control logic so in both in both planes
so like movement and aiming it's a more
frantic horror and that was just one of
the ways the game tackled horror with
the brand new emphasis on action horror
and with zombies I'm sorry I've been
saying zombies and that's a lie what I
mean is
yet another way Resident Evil 4 updated
its horror to complement these new
mechanics was all new enemies who
weren't zombies but would still terrify
the player and cause tension even though
you're now action both Jackson and Leon
Kennedy with cool hair I wish I had
suddenly there's chainsaw dudes who
don't die even when you shoot their
faces with a shotgun suddenly what you
thought were zombies aren't I mean it's
right there at the beginning of the game
it ain't a zombie instead they're
gennados or villagers infected by Lots
plagas who occasionally do this
meaning shooting their heads is
sometimes a very very bad idea then
there's creative enemies like Gyarados
who are blind but have giant Claws and
bum rush at any sound they hear and
still manage to absolutely terrify
my favorite scariest grossest enemy in
re4 has to be
um the novista doors that you find in
the sewer of the castle slash dungeon
having five to ten of those guys like
right in your face like just flying
around and like skittering around in
front of you and kicking you across the
room and then jumping on top of you and
melting your face off and then you see
the melted face like that is it's
terrifying so the enemy design was scary
and beyond that they were able to deal
with your newfound power and speaking of
Newfound power there was yet another
thing the re-14 implemented in a secret
lab that wasn't even talked about until
way later
if you were good at the game secretly
the game got harder because let's be
real if you're overly good at something
that ain't scary so the Resident Evil 14
added Dynamic difficulty for the sake of
keeping the player from getting
comfortable also if you weren't very
good at the game they can get a little
easier so hey a little something for
everybody and here's the thing Capcom
still hasn't acknowledged that Resident
Evil 4 uses Dynamic difficulty so
Pretend This section of the video
doesn't exist and it's our little secret
[Music]
yet another notable change to re4 came
from its writing Resident Evil 4 is
notorious for going absolutely over the
top with amazingly cheesy one-liners my
favorite one-liner in the original re4
is right after the krauser knife fight
right before you fight u3 Sadler calls
you on the phone and he can't remember
the name of u3 so he just refers to it
as it it should keep you busy can't
remember the name huh a senior moment
perhaps it's so stupid where's everyone
going bingo I knew you'd be fine if you
landed on your butt I'm starting to get
worried don't you mean lonely just
because you killed my small time
subordinate Sadler your small time wanna
know something interesting about it come
closer closer closer this wasn't in the
Japanese version of the game that's
right something that'll help make game
pop in the west was put in by a
translator you know that famous Bingo
line I just showed Leon say well in
Japanese the text for what he says is
donut Teru which roughly translates to
what's going on so you know non-existent
so what I want you to do is put yourself
in a 2005 mindset
year is 2005. Resident Evil 4 is just
released you've heard of the survival
horror series but interest in the
popular games has waned but what's this
the new Resident Evil 4 is being shown
in gaming magazines and it looks like
something completely new and completely
different what's crackalackin home
Skillets usually horror games are
wiggity whack but this new Resident Evil
game is thebomb.com let's peace out and
play that [__] Booyah Resident Evil 4
didn't just cater to horror fans it also
catered to action video game fans and
beyond that as the game was so
revolutionary it was interesting The
Gamers as a whole it was something
completely new and absolutely
revitalized interest in the Resident
Evil franchise as a whole so in 2005
Resident Evil 4 a game that was kinda
resident evily but also kind of not
resident evily came out to glowing
reviews and monstrous sales between the
PS2 and GameCube the game sold a
whopping 3.9 million units and that
doesn't include the 2007 Wii version
which would raise sales to 5.9 million
this was the best-selling Resident Evil
game since re2 with appeal of survival
horror dying Resident Evil 4 brought an
all-new dose of relevancy to the then
dying genre 2009's Resident Evil 5 went
on to sell 9.84 million units during its
initial run beating out re2 and on this
one I think we can all agree it was
thanks to the popularity and success of
re4 remember before Resident Evil 4
every game following Resident Evil 2 had
sold less and less units Resident Evil 6
sold over 10 million units during this
initial run unfortunately suddenly a
franchise that was slowly but surely
sinking had once again become one of the
most successful and popular franchises
out there and if you like horror re7
brought the series back to its horrific
roots with a game that as much as I
truly truly love re1 honestly scared me
more and also it sold over 11 million
copies Resident Evil Village to date has
sold over 6.5 4 million and Resident
Evil 2 to 3 were remade in the vein of
re4 to positive reviews and sales
yeah the impact our E4 had on the series
and the gaming industry as a whole is
that it just changed it it changed
everything I mean like I remember I
watched a video uh from someone who I
can't recall right now that also brought
up how like every game is Gears of War
and it's like no every game is re4 like
re4 invented that camera system and its
impact is still being felt to this day
you don't really get a whole lot of
games uh like that where it's where it's
so groundbreaking and so Innovative not
only for its time but for as many
possible years to follow survival Horror
in the tradition of Resident Evil 1 were
fantastic games while there are still
occasional games like signalus being
released modern horror games have
completely shifted to new trends most of
the old school survival horror
franchises have just petered out however
we all still know Resident Evil and
that's not a fluke it's not just because
Resident Evil 1 and 2 were popular or
because it had a terrible series of
movies I'll never understand the appeal
of Silent Hill's first film adaptation
was far better shame on all of you
Resident Evil 4 carried the torch for
Resident Evil through a slowing of
interest and survival horror it
completely revitalized the series and
introduced it to New fans and was able
to pave a path for Resident Evil until
its next big comeback into popular
relevance with Resident Evil 7 but you
have to wonder if Resident Evil 4 hadn't
happened would there be a Resident Evil
7 or would Resident Evil have become
capcom's next Mega Man in that is a
series I love but Capcom is mostly
abandoned Resident Evil 4 might be
divisive for some but I think there's no
doubt that it saved the Resident Evil
franchise thank you so much for watching
the first episode of How It's saved it's
actually one of many shows we're
launching here at Gamespot which is
super exciting another one that I highly
recommend you check out is the Kurt
Locker hosted by our very own Kurt in
Davina which takes a look at the role
that gaming plays in our lives to
celebrate launching these new shows
we're also doing a giveaway so check out
the pinned comment for info on how you
could win uh Resident Evil 4 remake Jedi
Survivor or even a PlayStation 5 us
residents only turns on conditions apply
also a huge thank you to Susie for
adding her steep re knowledge to this
episode please make sure to check out
and subscribe to her channel the sphere
Hunter